I'd like I'd hasten to add it wasn't 15
seconds it was 30 seconds it was 15
minutes and it didn't happen in China it
happened in
Malaysia and my w wife to be was not
Chinese but of Indian descent Indian
Malaysia so apart from a few
inaccuracies it was
accurate
now I want to clarify first of all what
this motion is about or what it's not
about is probably the best way of
putting it this is not a proposal that
liberal western style
democracy will always be in appropriate
for China I don't know what the
situation is going to be like in 25
years or 50 years I don't even know what
the situation is likely to be in the
West in that period what we're
discussing is something much more
specific
likewise we're not suggesting Al
certainly I'm not suggesting and the
motion is not suggesting that what
happens in China and the arrangements
that are propo appropriate for China in
this period should be transplanted into
our own societies I would not argue that
for a moment in fact on the contrary I
would say that the reason Western
democracies have grown up in the west
has been because because of the history
and the culture of our
societies and we need to pay due respect
I would suggest to China and the
differences of its history and culture
in the same
way what this motion is
about is a
country which is a developing country
which in the middle of the 20th
century was extr extremely poor which
had
suffered 200 years during a 200e period
of more or less and I mean this
literally economic stagnation its GDP at
the end of this period was more or less
the same as it was in the first part of
the 19th
century and it had been invaded and
partially colonized by many countries
including our own in
1949 China was a mess and a basket case
and the task that confronted China was
how with this vast
country could they transform
it and they made quite a few false moves
un false starts so when D sha ping came
to power in
1978 he
identified the two crucial tasks tasks
of China the
first was an overwhelming focus on the
need for economic growth and secondly
intimately tied to that was the need for
a huge reduction in poverty in a poverty
stricken country at that time in
1978 the Chinese economy was
12th of the size of the American
economy and since that move from the end
of the 70s in the direction of economic
reform we have
seen the most remarkable economic
transformation in human history a
population of 1.3 billion people 1 of
humanity its economy growing at 10% a
year to the point where today the
Chinese
economy is half the size of the American
economy and there's a general view now
that the Chinese economy will overtake
the American economy in size around
about
18 this is truly remarkable and I want
to correct you Anson because it it's
just not true that the British
experience or the American Experience of
industrialization in any way Compares
with the Chinese achievement the British
Industrial Revolution between 1780 and
1830 which was the key period or you can
push it to 1840 the growth rate was
around about on average 1 and a half% a
year 1 and a half% a year and that was a
population of what 20 30 million at that
time probably more more like 20 million
at that time or take America you mention
America well the period between the end
of the Civil War the mid 1860s to 1914
the American growth rate never exceeded
on average something like
3.5% and that of course again was a much
smaller population so that is why I
suggest that this is the most remarkable
economic transformation there has ever
been and it has been presided over
by the Chinese
government and it has lifted I mean
let's remember this as well if you look
at the reduction in global poverty over
the last 30 years China is overwhel is
responsible for the overwhelming bulk of
that reduction in poverty if you take
China out of the equation actually the
global performance has been very
disappointing now I challenge The View
that this does not the Chinese
government does not enjoy the support of
overwhelming mass of Chinese people I
don't know you know if you look at for
example the Pew Global attitude surveys
uh the uh support for the Chinese
government is is extraordinary
impressive if you look at Tony s's work
uh from the Harvard Kennedy School uh in
terms of the levels of satisfaction
amongst the Chinese in terms of their
government you know the ratings are
extremely high indeed and is it so
surprising if your living standards are
growing as they have been now for a
while at roughly the same pace of
economic growth 10% a year then you know
it's quite likely that your PO your
population is going to be uh rather
pleased uh with uh with government and I
challenge the idea also that you know
the political uh of course there are
many things that are different from what
we're used to which we would certainly
object to but the idea that the sort of
political atmosphere the political
environment is Frozen is a mistake I
mean the idea that every you know you
said descent is crushed excuse me I mean
there are about 150 Mass thousand Mass
incidents every year in China in which
people uh which mainly consists of
farmers objecting to what they regard to
be the illicit seizure of their land by
local government flogging it off to uh
to to to to property developers and
these actions are well you know they're
reported in lots of places and they take
place and it's not true that they're all
suppressed and sometimes when there is
suppression like in wukan actually the
authorities are forced to retreat or
take the wave of strikes in guandong
Province and in along the eastern coast
in Shanghai in two in 2010 and 2011 tens
and tens of thousands of people on
strike and they were not
suppressed they were allowed to happen
and the result huge wage increases the
minimum wage in Beijing was increased uh
during that period by 30% Shanghai
roughly similar and so on huge lift in
living standard so it's not good enough
to be frank to paint China as this sort
of autocracy with a central government
which suppresses everything there has
been a huge shift in the personal
freedoms of the average Chinese since
the death of Mao you've only got to go
to Shanghai or to gueno or to chungu and
you can see it on the streets and it's
not true that everything is censor
actually the censorship in China is much
lighter than it used to be much lighter
and the access to information sure there
are controls on the internet but quite
frankly if you want to you can get
random so this is a society which is
throbbing actually and it's vibrating
waiting with debate contrary to the
picture that ansen has presented which
is a very common picture presented uh to
uh Western uh
audiences
um I wanted to just say something else
you see my concentration in what I want
to say is really about China as a
developing country now let's take a
comparative example
India in 1950 which has got in many ways
a most impressive democracy in 1950 the
Chinese economy and the Indian economy
were more or less the same
size today the Chinese economy is four
times the size of the Indian
economy why because the economic
strategy pursued by the Chinese has been
far more successful than the strategy
which is been employed by India and
India has a great problem it's got a
most impressive democracy which is what
we celebrate and an extremely corrupt
and inefficient state which cannot
deliver in other words in that sense
it's opposite to China and the poverty
reduction in China has been far anyone
who goes to China go goes to India can
see this has been far more successful uh
than anything that has been achieved uh
in India now I think also we need a bit
of humility about this China is a huge
way way pointed out huge country on a
scale that is unimaginable to us in the
west so we and we its task has been how
to it has been an industrial revolution
essentially economic takeoff as Roso
described it the shift from the
countryside to Industry uh around the
time of Duna pinging it was not much
more than 20% of the population lived in
the urban centers today it's 50% now
what was the situation politically
excuse me in the West in Europe in the
United States when we were having our
industrial revolutions how many Western
countries were democracies at the time
of their industrial revolutions shall I
tell you how
many
zero
zero in uh Britain uh uh in in
1850 uh finally 1th of men had the right
to vote that was after the conclusion of
the Industrial Revolution and it was not
until the 1880s that most men had the
vote but not women or take America it
was not until
1860 that most white men gained the vote
but not blacks really until the 1960s
and women in 1920 and if you look at
Europe exactly the same pattern their
industrial revolutions were accomplished
essentially in France in Germany in
Italy and so on before uh they had
democracy so when so when we say they
should be like us well actually we
should speak we should speak with more
modesty because we weren't like what we
want them to be um uh uh during uh this
particular historical phase I would like
to conclude by just saying
this first of all I would
ask our my my country to be more modest
and more humble in the face of China's
extraordinary
achievement and not think our task is to
say why the hell can't you be like
us but on the contrary I think what we
need with the rise of China is a much
more humble attitude which recognizes
and respects their achievement and also
is willing to learn from them and what
we're going to face I think now is not
just feeling that democracy is important
but also we need to learn from the
Chinese about State
competence this is not a subject that's
been discussed in the west but it will
be discussed in the west and here we
have much to learn from the Chinese
thank you very much